madame la Première ministre la droite
française a toujours assumé de Jacques
Chirac à Nicolas Sarkozy de réformer les
retraites pour sauvegarder notre système
par répartition la répartition c'est un
principe de solidarité dans lequel c'est
le travail des Français qui finance les
retraites c'est le contraire du chacun
pour soi c'est le système le plus
protecteur pour les Français les plus
modestes aujourd'hui ce système est
menacé là où il y avait quatre actifs
pour un retraité dans les années 70 il
n'y en a plus qu'un virgule 7 les
déficits annoncés auront une conséquence
et une seule la baisse du niveau des
pensions pour les retraités et nous le
refusons
la réforme que nous voulons elle tient
en quelques principes d'abord elle doit
être progressive le recul de l'âge ne
doit intervenir qu'au rythme d'un
trimestre par an jusqu'à 63 ans à la fin
de ce quinquennat 64 ans dans le suivant
ensuite elle doit être juste et
permettre à celui qui a commencé plus
tôt de partir à la retraite plutôt dès
lors qu'il a tout ce trimestre elle doit
aussi être équitable en demandant le
même effort à tous les Français publics
privés régime spéciaux enfin soyons
clairs il est hors de question que
l'État s'empare des réserves du privé
l'argent des retraites doit aller au
retraité et à eux seuls mais par dessus
tout il faut réparer une injustice c'est
2 millions de retraités qui ont cotisé
toute leur vie ont travaillé dur au des
carrières complètes souvent des femmes
des commerçants des artisans qui
perçoivent aujourd'hui des retraites
indignes autour de 900 euros par mois
c'est un digne d'un grand pays comme le
nôtre êtes-vous prête madame la Première
ministre alors garantir à eux aussi une
retraite minimum de 1200 euros et pas
seulement au futur retraités je vous le
dis très clairement c'est pour nous une
condition impérative merci beaucoup